scroll up to the far right look at your
[ __ ] eyes that's where you're holding
me you're trying to squeeze me and I'm
like ah attention British job captures
the Roswell alien look like a [ __ ]
alien there oh my god that's always a
bit of it your honor who took that
picture it salutes I know you were
squeezing me but you were being nice
where does that that was at the comedy
show that's right dude I had a guy at
Brea come up to me works for a company
that rhymes with masa and he and he you
know he told me about the alien stuff
from his line of work yeah again rhymes
with masa yeah and he works for them
sure listen
yes his line of work he said aliens do
exist good of course they do but they've
never made contact with her I believe
I'm also said that guy's full of [ __ ] of
course and I want to say this and thank
you for that because I'm but also don't
Amy and quits enemy alien footage oh I
know I know listen all of you all of you
who believe this I believe that
extraterrestrials exist and we have to
they have to exist because the universe
is so big right but here's the thing
that guy I listen that [ __ ] podcast
you kept I was my [ __ ] I want my
money and my time back you didn't pay
hey Joe don't put that guy on that guy's
little research been telling that same
story he's a [ __ ] liar and if you
believe that guy or any of this [ __ ]
about Roswell that we have UFO eat a red
dick all of you to cream to eat off if I
give you the green alien dick you too
green bean you all the green alien dicks
no there's no truth you [ __ ] flying
saucer believe in Peter B here's the
other thing you thought you know the guy
that works for Cummings with Raza and
yeah rassa with Ryan he was saying that
guy there's no knowledge of the ecology
went to and he went to Paris for college
thank you and also the description now
this is this guy he's a lion this guy
works for coming rhymes with rasa he was
saying that that guy a lot of stuff he
was describing is actually from a movie
they can look up haha that's from the
eighties I love it
he's crazy I when I was having migraines
he did have money
grains do have migraine like bacon
migraines he was gonna pick migraines
and what I realized says like oh this
guy he's actually batshit crazy not only
that he's a nerd who found a way to get
a little bit of notoriety and people
surround them and it gives him faint up
by this I got him late what's that
you're not buying it
oh no oh what the crazy guy the crazy
guy nameless laser on on Lazar Lazar
gives you a bomb laser the crate crazy
Lazar are they buying Rogan
nah it's I can't wait I can't wait for
the next bike companion it's all a
[ __ ] lie okay they're all a lie yeah
it's all a lie I can see that I see both
sides no no no what
there's no no both sides no no there's
only one side and if you believe there's
another side full of [ __ ] eat our
[ __ ] green dick dick okay eat it stop
sending me you all of you get don't send
me any [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
well got secret government agencies to
get make contact you eat a red dick too
and a green deck no doll this is okay
I got a glory hole thing get over here
I'll suck you suck no I mean it's your
green dick through the hole get over
here you'll stop you are sure we'll see
who's a lady who's an alien what
seasoning on your dirt you squirt that
alien goos in his mouth who whatever the
other point is we are extant you watch
the the laser thing I saw part of it
were you buying it or no so annoying
things I dug the problem is the the
documentarian who was there he's
completely that was also well hey Rogan
and hey Joe the guy who doesn't suffer
most at all same guy who doesn't suffer
fools at all sting only why would you
give that guy some time he just likes it
though
Joe just likes it he doesn't care look
at interesting it is interesting no it
was entertaining show yeah it was good
fiction but what's even good fiction
it's all six million viewers
oh god people are into it yeah I know we
all it would be amazing if we if when
you're cutting that shill poor guy you
know what you know what I hate say it's
Bob lasers an infant that's what's going
on in a [ __ ] infants get
you're all infants UFO hoaxster but I
think it's great it's actually fun just
don't you know don't take it seriously
it's fine people thought you and I were
really mad at each other no even if we
are mad at each other it doesn't matter
no you find kids not get in because I
believe in aliens and Brian's a
government shell yeah let's not how this
thing ends and I said I'd sent Brennan
in Texaco hey this [ __ ] guy all the
[ __ ] I want listen and you go you're a
government ship oh my god it was when
you do the trade government secrets of
there are there are military courts that
you go to jail you know yeah you should
yeah you have to get ya there guys gonna
hunt you down yeah you know I had plenty
of those guys call me text me - they
were like I mean hit me up on TMZ like
hey dude just so you know I work for a
television agency
it's my job to hunt those guys down if
they search kitchen it doesn't work
there's a whole system and then when
they ask him yeah listen gun to my head
have aliens touchdown Earth I would say
yes do we have any proof no but I bet
they checked that was like yeah as if
you guys are [ __ ] crazy where I
there's a kill each other there's war
it's gotta be there's gotta be extra
trumpeting claim we don't know it yeah
Bob lazer work on the UFOs probably not
hey you know what though the government
the military has secret weaponry that we
don't know about that some might even
look like like a UFOs look I mean look
at the stealth bomber the stealth bomber
bring that out definitely look like it's
a giant blob but but it but it evades
radar they Abdullah's now because if
they look different that they have where
they have weaponry that they're working
on that is so hot top secret that I'm
sure maybe is in places like area 51 Bob
Lee I'd [ __ ] there that's the new one
that's allowable Bob laser looks like an
alien yeah look at that thing come on
tell me that doesn't look like a
spaceship nothing looks [ __ ] now
guarantee the US government has weaponry
that looks like it's alien technology
and probably behaves like it they're
working on [ __ ] that makes you like they
have stuff that makes it look invisible
it goes crazy
by the time technology and the even
though I think Obama said by the time
technology comes to the masses yeah the
White House and the government's been
working out for four to six years yeah
yeah that time we get it
they're like they've already tried it
out I've seen it yeah oh yeah
there's a lot of that stuff Sherri's dr.
BOTS laser though there's a lot of
secret technology because we keep it
secret we don't want other countries to
have it no doubt look at that [ __ ]
thing looking new lookit am damn good
luck fighting the thing looks US
military Jesus I mean come on
yeah I just watched you know just
mention Bob laser and then that podcast
blew up poor Jo koy was part of that he
got caught up in the infant yet causing
a friendly fire he got him caught him me
but then he hit me up he's a great dude
I love that I loved you okay this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]